Tyler is with us in Phoenix Arizona hi
Tyler how are you I'm doing all right
Dave how are you better than I deserve
what's up I just wanted to call and ask
you your opinion about credit repair
companies I just recently started
listening to you probably about a month
now but it's hard for me to get in on
your radio station I I'm a installer for
a cable company and I'm in and out of my
truck so well you just got the group you
just got through well let me tell you
here's there's the story on credit
repair okay there's only one way that
your credit is repaired well there's two
ways actually one is if you have a bill
that you have not paid and you've got an
outstanding collections you pay it okay
all right and then it continues to
report but it gets older and older and
older so like back in arts 17 you paid
off your last collection and now it's
2021
it'll still be on there for seven years
but it doesn't really count against you
much after it gets three or four years
old an old paid collection but there is
no repair for unpaid collections it's
going to continue to ding your credit
period the other repair that you can do
to credit is if something is reported in
accurately there's a collection on there
or there's a part of the account that's
inaccurately reported you can challenge
the repair you can challenge the
inaccuracy under federal law the Federal
Fair Debt Collection Practices Act or
I'm sorry the Federal Fair Credit
Reporting Act allows you to challenge
and you write a letter certified mail
return receipt requested so your proof
of delivery on a certain date that says
as of this date I am challenging the
accuracy of my visa with Wells Fargo it
is inaccurately reported okay then they
have 30 days to verify the account and
the reporting with Wells Fargo in that
example or they have to remove the in
higher entry okay alright and so let's
say they don't respond at all in 30 days
then you'd go back and demand oh this is
a 30 day old account you go back and
demand that it get taken off completely
and it takes the account any reporting
good or bad regarding that account
completely wipes it off of there they
can put it back on later if they reira
port it but you can get it taken back
off again you know so you can have
inaccurate things removed and that
repairs your credit what some of the
credit repair people do that is is
basically fraud is they go in and
challenge all of your negative accounts
as being inaccurate even though they are
accurate and some of them even though
they're accurate won't respond within
the 30 days and they get wiped off but
that's fraud that's fraud worse than
that some of the credit repair people
will talk to you about getting a new
social security number and like setting
up a new identity which is even more
fraudulent yeah we didn't know you go to
jail for yeah the first example is
pretty much what this company is saying
and it was $225 to start off and then
$100 a month to a total of 20 to 50 we
would the first example of challenging
everything yeah yeah but if your
challenge is what they said that they do
yeah if you challenge everything even if
it's accurate and you challenge its
accuracy you reported as being
inaccurate that's called lying right
it's fraud so basically at what I should
do is cancel this out because they have
a money-back guarantee if you don't see
anything in the first month of doing it
cancel it you're doing with scam artists
is what we're saying dude they are
telling you that their business model is
to lie alright that's what they told you
if I'm because I'm paying off stuff in
your debt snowball way and I've been
doing little things here and there
trying to get ahead but then this came
up and it sounded too good to be true
but you know then you get all this
information you get over
so sure okay I think I'm gonna go ahead
and do it but but basically you hard you
hard off you've hired a firm to live for
you right and you don't want to do that
yeah that's that's it's a scam you don't
wanna do that and it's gonna come back
and bite you in the butt later too by
the way
so you know if something that is
accurate gets removed because it's
inaccurate you don't you mean I can
promise you that Wells Fargo is gonna
download that same file back into the
credit reporting software again and it's
gonna pop back on there because you
still have an account with them you know
so the only way to get them off is to
pay them off close the account and then
let it age out over seven years and it
completely disappears everything goes
off in seven years from the time it was
paid from the time it was last reported
the last activity was done except for a
chapter seven bankruptcy which stays on
for ten years but yeah the answer is
it's a scam you've participated
accidentally in a scam stop it hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]